[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning the
coronavirus pandemic is suddenly hitting
harder in many parts of the united
states
in fact 31 states now report an increase
in the average number of new cases
and one of the hot spots is in wisconsin
which saw a record number of covert
related hospitalizations just yesterday
take a look at this time lapse video
showing a new medical facility being
built at the wisconsin state fair park
it's a facility
that will admit patients who are not
seriously ill but still in need of care
and our mololengi is at the site it's in
west allis outside of milwaukee
moeller good morning to you what are
officials they're doing to get this
outbreak under control
well good morning tony as you mentioned
here's the the field hospital here 530
bed
field hospital that health officials are
planning to open sometime
next week that will take in patients who
need low level care of course that
will hopefully help alleviate some of
the burden some of the pressure on
wisconsin hospitals that are currently
operating
at 85 percent capacity this as the state
continues to add
thousands of new cases every single day
wisconsin is in a much different and
more dire place today
and our health care systems are being
overwhelmed
a sobering warning from wisconsin
governor tony evers on wednesday
coronavirus hospitalizations here are up
more than
70 percent over the last two weeks and
in some regions of the state
icu's are at 90 percent capacity
now state officials say hospitals across
wisconsin are reporting
imminent staffing shortages it's scary
and i
i'm scared of fatigue i'm scared of
losing nurses because they're getting
fatigued and
in sick jennifer bozetsky is an icu
nurse at ascension saint elizabeth
hospital in appleton wisconsin
she says while the state's new field
hospital outside milwaukee will help
with bed capacity
wisconsin's front line health care
workers are already stretched thin
she told us she's been working 16 hour
shifts
what's the message that you want to send
out to folks in wisconsin
that it may not be affecting you right
now and you
you feel that in your bubble you're safe
but you know what we thought we were
safe how many months ago
when our numbers went down and now our
bubble is bursting
it's not just wisconsin nine states
reported a record number of coronavirus
hospitalizations on wednesday
and after monday night's matchup between
the kansas city chiefs and the new
england patriots
reigning defensive player of the year
stefan gilmore announced
he had tested positive for the virus
wednesday gilmore was one of at least
three
nfl players to test positive yesterday
at least four nfl teams reportedly now
have
active cases on their rosters and nfl
chief medical officer dr alan sills said
yesterday
the league could put the entire season
on hold if the need arises
we've said all along every option is on
the table we've we've never taken any
option off the table which includes as
you said some type of pause or reset
well in a statement dr sill said that
the league was not blindsided by this
that they expected positive cases all
along and that their approach has been
risk mitigation not elimination anthony
mola thank you